-We're here with Jean Smart.
We're talking about "SNL."
I have to ask --
they did a very funny
"Mare of Easttown" sketch
called "Murdur Durdur."
Did you see it?
-Kate Winslet actually
sent it to me on my phone.
It was hilarious!
I don't know how they put that
together so fast.
That was brilliant.
-You have a wonderful show
Obviously, it's very different
from "Hacks."
Is it cool right now
to be working on two shows
that people are seeing
at the same time
that have such
different characters?
-Oh, absolutely.
It's fun, yeah, having the
both on at the same time.
And they're both so good.
I mean, I'm really proud
of both productions.
And, you know, HBO.
I love HBO.
They're very good to me.
-[ Laughs ] HBO has been
very good to you.
-Yes, yes.
-I mean, well, you've been
very good to HBO.
You elevate the work.
You elevate the work, Jean
-That's it, that's it.
-[ Laughs ]
-And Kate Winslet --
I can't say enough
good things about Kate Winslet
She's a doll.
She's just a doll.
-One thing that is in common
in both shows is,
you've done some fantastic
iPad acting.
-[ Laughing ]
-Well, I'm just saying.
I believe you're playing
"Fruit Ninja"
in "Mare of Easttown."
You throw an iPad in "Hacks.
Now, was there
an iPad coach on set?
-[ Laughing ]
No. There should have been
Should have been.
-Well, I figure
obviously self-coached,
because you don't need one
-[ Laughing ]
Yeah, that was fun.
-I think this speaks to ho
seriously you take your acting
But I heard that you actually --
I mean, this is
nothing funny about this.
You physically hurt yourself
Was it on set of "Mare"?
-Yeah. Yeah, God.
Apparently, I'll do anything
for a laugh.
There's a scene in the sho
where I'm sitting playing card
and drinking with the priest
as I do every week.
And my phone rings, and I'
too lazy to get out of my chair.
So I lean over
to the kitchen counter
to get my phone, and I fal
on the floor, out of my chair.
They had a coach for that, too
They had a stand-in to do that
I said, "I can fall out of m
own chair, thank you very much."
So, there was another scen
where Kate and Guy
are going out on a date.
And I'm playing her mother
so I'm craning my neck
to spy on them.
And I'm sitting on a railing
above the stairwell
that goes down
to the front door.
And I thought it would be funn
if I pretended to almost fall.
It's just sort of Helen's thing.
And the first five takes
went really well,
and then I leaned
just a little too far.
The next take,
I went over the railing
and down the flight of stair
and broke my rib
and got a concussion.
I was in the hospital
for five days.
-Five days?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
And Kate was so sweet.
She always called me "Mummy"
on the show,
'cause I played her mother
My back hurt so bad,
'cause I hadn't just
cracked the rib.
It broke in half.
And my back --
I thought I had broken my back
I was lying in a heap
at the bottom of the stairs,
and she was behind me
kind of supporting my back
and she was saying...
[British accent]
"It's all right, Mummy.
They're coming.
It's all right, Mummy."
[ Normal voice ] And I'm finally
in the ambulance,
and the guy in the back
of the ambulance
is getting ready
to give me some morphine,
and he says, "Boy, your daughter
was sure worried about you."
And I said, "My what?
My daughter's not here."
I went, "Oh, no.
No, she plays my d"--
I said, "Didn't you
recognize her?"
I said," That was Kate Winslet."
And he was like, "What?!
I missed Kate Winslet?!"
And I'm going,
"Morphine, please!
Yeah, you can fan out late
after I get my drugs."
-He probably gave himself
morphine to get over
the pain of having missed
Kate Winslet.
So, they obviously must have
had to change the whole
shooting schedule
thanks to you
going down the stairs.
-Unbelievably --
unbelievably -- they didn't,
and I actually wrapped
on schedule.
Because when I fell
down the stairs,
I was five minutes away
from going to the airport,
'cause I had four days off
and I was gonna go home
and see my family.
But instead, I spent five days
in the hospital.
And then, I had to quarantin
for three days,
which was most of that weekend
And I went back on schedul
on a lot of pills [Chuckles]
and finished my last
few days' work.
-I mean, it would
have been great if
that was your last shot,
and while you were just
lying in a heap,
you heard,
"That's a wrap on Jean."
[ Laughter ]
-No, I do recall yelling,
"I hope you got that on film!"
[ Laughter ]
-You know, people have bee
saying recently,
this is the Jean Smart-aissance,
because we've seen you
in so many critically acclaime
shows recently.
Do you feel like you're living
through the Jean Smart-aissance,
or is this just business
as usual for an actor?
-Well, first of all,
I challenge you to spell that.
But, no, I mean, I just --
You know, I feel like
I hit the jackpot,
and I don't take it
for granted at all --
especially at this
late stage of the game.
No, I've just been given so many
extraordinary opportunitie
the last few years
that it kind of led to this.
And this is just like
a dream job.
If they had given me a paper
and pencil and said,
"Describe your next job
that you want --
everything you want,"
it would have been this job.
-You know, it's interesting,
'cause the clip we showed
of "Hacks," you obviously
are playing someone
who talks about how
it never gets easier.
And that's talking about
stand-up comedy,
but have you found, as you
career has sort of expande
and you've done all these
different things --
has it gotten easier for you
-Yes, it has.
I mean, I don't think I'm
necessarily a better actor now
than I was 20 or 30 years ago.
The thing about actors is --
and even that tiny percentag
of actors who work a lot -
even most of them,
I would dare say,
rarely get the chance to sho
what they really are capable of.
Most actors never, ever ge
the chance to show what they do.
You know, like, other people
like painters and singers
and dancers and writers,
they can do it
any time they want.
Doesn't mean they'll
get paid, necessarily,
but they can actually do it.
But as an actor, you have to
sort of be given permissio
to do your work.
You know, invited
-Well, I want to give
my great gratitude
to everyone who has been
sending you invitations
in recent years, because it ha
been so much fun to watch.
It's always a pleasure
to see you, Jean.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Thank you.
You, too, Seth. Thank you.
-"Hacks" is streaming
on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."